wer verhandlungen führen will mit
afghanistans neuen machthabern der muss
nach doha reisen die luxushotels des
emirats sind das diplomatische parkett
im wohl klimatisierten räumen auf
eleganten polstern empfangen die taliban
ihre gesprächspartner amerikaner
europäer doch wie weit reicht ihr
einfluss noch hat das was hier
vereinbart wird in kabul gültigkeit
wir fragen ein interview mit dem
sprecher der taliban in doha immer
wieder werden wir vertröstet dann vor
wenigen stunden klappt es doch so
hölscher hin gibt sich weltoffen spricht
englisch sind die taliban gespalten wer
hat das sagen bei diesen schwer
durchschaubaren neuen herrschern
was uns betrifft wir sind eins wenn es
eine anordnung der führung gibt dann
müssen alle bis zu den fußsoldaten das
befolgen und anwenden
2.000 kilometer entfernt am hamid karzai
flughafen seitdem die letzten
us-soldaten abgeflogen sind hat sich
hier eine besonders militante gruppe der
taliban positioniert kämpfer des
berüchtigten hakkani clans sie haben
waffen munition und militärfahrzeuge der
afghanischen armee und tragen uniform
ein schein von ordnung doch wer durch
die stadt fährt erlebt vor allem chaos
flüchtlinge die sich in den parks
drängen hungrig und durstig in sorge um
ihre zukunft
gloria und reza halten sich in ihrer
wohnung versteckt als journalist traut
der 25-jährige den zusagen der taliban
nicht er fürchtet racheakte
vorhergesagt den sie kabul eingenommen
haben und ganz afghanistan ist die
bedrohung für uns sehr gestiegen zu
arbeiten ist nicht möglich auch nicht
neu anzufangen
auch nora die bislang als hebamme
gearbeitet hat ist überzeugt im neuen
afghanistan ist kein platz für sie ihren
kleinen sohn und ihren mann aber nicht
es gibt jetzt keine möglichkeit mehr für
frauen zu arbeiten
und mein mann bekommt drohungen wegen
seiner arbeit sein leben ist in gefahr
trotzdem wollen sie offen vor unserer
kamera reden denn sie haben jetzt nur
eine hoffnung dass sie ihn an
europäisches land ausreisen können
in kürze wollen die neuen machthaber
ihre regierung bekanntgeben doch langsam
wächst die erkenntnis
afghanistan zu erobern mag einfach
gewesen sein eines der ärmsten und
gefährlichsten länder der welt zu
regieren etwas anderes dass es sich in
einem muslimischen land durchaus
angenehm leben lässt haben die taliban
in doha in den vergangenen jahren zu
schätzen gelernt seit 2013 haben sie
ihre politische vertretung im emirat und
anders als vor 20 jahren wollen die
moderneren von ihnen keinen paria staat
mehr regieren
internationale zusammenarbeit auf
augenhöhe
das sei das ziel erklärt für ihn schien
mir das auch deutschland seine
entwicklungshilfe aussetzt schmerzt
die leute unterhalb der armutsgrenze
leben und dann kommt jemand und friert
ihre gelder ein ist das human erlauben
humanitäre werte das
[Musik]
um an geld zu kommen verpflichten sich
die taliban deutschlands wichtigste
forderung zu erfüllen und 40.000
afghanische ortskräfte mit familien
ausreisen zu lassen
in dieser hinsicht ist unsere politik
klar jeder der gültige papiere hat kann
das land verlassen
auch mit kommerziellen flügen
und dann muss der sprecher zum nächsten
termin in den folgenden tagen wird sich
zeigen worauf auch die diplomaten in
doha jetzt warten ob den worten taten
folgen